ziel unserer und erregung unterredung
mit den ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten war ist unser land
auf die bevorstehende nächste corona
welle vorzubereiten
ich bin froh dass der von uns
eingesetzte expertenrat am wochenende
eine so klare und im übrigen einhellige
einschätzung zu omikron abgegeben hat
ich danke an dieser stelle den
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern und all den übrigen
experten für diese wichtige arbeit
ihre wissenschaftliche einschätzung ist
die grundlage für die politischen
entscheidungen die wir jetzt treffen
und ich bin dankbar dass wir so zügig im
kreis der 16 länder und der
bundesregierung zusammengekommen sind um
zu besprechen welche maßnahmen zu
ergreifen sind damit unser land gut
durch die nächste zeit kommt
lassen sie mich noch eines vorweg sagen
ich kann jeden und jede verstehen die
nichts mehr hören will von corona von
mutationen und neuen virus varianten
doch wir können und dürfen nicht die
augen verschließen vor dieser nächsten
welle die sich vor uns aufzutürmen
beginnen
im augenblick befinden wir uns noch in
einer seltsamen zwischenzeit die
maßnahmen auf die wir uns ende november
verständigt haben wirken überall und
flächendeckend gehen die
infektionszahlen deutlich zurück wir uns
das robert koch institut meldet ganz
allmählich verringert sich sogar auch
die belegung der intensivstation etwas
auch wenn die belastung der
beschäftigten weiteren sehr groß ist und
wir in einzelnen regionen an der grenze
sind
das zeigt dass unsere strengen maßnahmen
seit ende november die erwünschte
wirkung zeigen die strikten
zugangsbeschränkung für ungeimpfte der
zusätzliche schutz durch test um sowie
die starke booster kampagne der
vergangenen wochen waren richtig wir
bekommen die vierte welle also langsam
im griff
das wäre eigentlich eine gute nachricht
eigentlich denn diese pandemie lehrt uns
so schnell wie erhofft ist es nicht
vorbei es droht nun bereits die welle 5
in großbritannien dänemark und auch in
den usa ist omikron bereits auf dem
vormarsch
diese variante des virus unterscheidet
sich in nicht unwesentlichen merkmalen
von denen zuvor sie ist nach
einschätzung der fachleute was die
infektionen betrifft noch aggressiver
und sind eigenschaften die es
ermöglichen den impfschutz stellenweise
zu unterlaufen selbst zweifach geimpfte
und auch genesene laufen hohe gefahr
sich mit dieser variante anzustecken
erst eine frische gusto rang eine
auffrischungsimpfung bietet einigermaßen
schutz gegen eine infektion
omikron ist leichter ansteckend
verbreitet sich schneller und wird die
zahl der infektionen in den kommenden
wochen massiv ansteigen lassen
darauf müssen wir uns jetzt einstellen
deshalb haben wir uns heute mit den 16
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten getroffen
noch ist omikron in deutschland nicht
flächendeckend aufgetreten aber
es ist nach derzeitiger einschätzung
bestenfalls nur eine frage von wenigen
wochen bis diese virusvariante sich auch
bei uns durchsetzen wird
deshalb müssen wir uns auch jetzt darauf
vorbereiten
wir folgen dabei den ratschlägen des
wissenschaftlichen expertengremiums
wo ich zu den einzelnen maßnahmen komme
noch ein wort zum zeitpunkt von dem die
neuen maßnahmen an gelten sollen wir
haben bewusst entschieden du weißt du
dich vor ort schon irgendwo eingeführt
sind sie erst nach weihnachten anlaufen
zu lassen die erfahrung der vergangenen
beiden jahre haben gezeigt dass
weihnachten und ostern
auch durch die
verhaltensweise der bürgerinnen und
bürger sich nicht als große pandemie
treiber diesen haben im gegenteil die
ferien haben die infektionszahlen bürger
oft verringert die familien scheinen
verantwortungsvoll und vorsichtig mit
diesen festtagen umzugehen im
beschränkten rahmen mit ausreichend
testen oder nötigen vorsicht auch für
diese festtage wünsche ich mir dass
möglichst viele wieder so vorgehen um
sich um ihre eltern und großeltern ihre
lieben zu schützen mit abstand mit
masken und mit zusätzlichen täglichen
tests auch wenn sie schon zweimal
geimpft sind testen sie sich bitte bevor
sie mit anderen menschen für die
weihnachtsfeiern zusammenkommen
diese pandemie hat uns in den
vergangenen 21 monaten gemeinsam sehr
viel abverlangt deshalb freuen sich
viele zu recht auf diese festtage im
trauten kreis der familie mit der
gebotenen vorsicht und der gebotenen
rücksicht ist das auch möglich
die impfungen sind ein ganz wichtiger
faktor im kampf gegen umgekommen seit
dem 18 november läuft umso erboster
kampagne bis zu 30 millionen impfungen
bis weihnachten habe ich und haben wir
als ziel ausgegeben viel spricht dafür
dass wir dieses ziel erreichen werden
doch corona macht keine weihnachtspause
bei unserer heutigen zusammenkunft haben
wir deshalb entschieden die impfkampagne
mit unverminderter kraft auch während
der feiertage zwischen den jahren und zu
beginn des neuen jahres fortzusetzen
als nächstes wollen wir bis ende januar
weitere 30 millionen booster impfung
erreichen
damit wären dann drei viertel der bürger
und bürger drei mal geimpft und die
buste empfang sondern künftig bereits
drei monate nach der zweiten impfung
möglich sein das kann ich hier sagen
wird auch die stiko zu unterstützen
impfen ist
unser ziel damit möglichst viele vor
omikron geschützt sind darunter verstehe
ich nicht nur auffrischungsimpfungen
sondern auch erst im 5 und 210 von
73,5 prozent der deutschen haben
inzwischen mindestens eine impfung als
nächstes zwischenziel möchte ich eine
impfquote von mindestens 80 prozent an
steuern und wenn wir das erreicht haben
müssen wir das nächste ziel in den blick
nehmen
bei aller unsicherheit die es über das
virus nach wie vor gibt wissen wir einst
das risiko für nicht geimpfte erwachsene
sich zu infizieren und schwer zu
erkranken steigt durch die neue variante
noch einmal weiter
deshalb mein appell lassen sie sich
impfen sind in eigenen schutz zum schutz
ihrer lieben unseren schutz von uns
allen wenn sie unsicher sind informieren
sie sich bei ihrem arzt oder ihrer
ärztin bei anderen fachleuten und fragen
sie die vielen die sich bereits haben
impfen lassen fast 60 millionen deutsche
sind inzwischen vollständig geimpft ohne
dass wir von schweren nebenwirkungen
oder langfristigen einschränkungen
erfahren hätten
ganz anders bei denjenigen die auf den
intensivstationen um ihr leben kämpfen
oder mit den langzeitfolgen der cupid
erkrankungen zu ringen haben
und so um den konkreten maßnahmen die
der bund und die länder heute
beschlossen haben und die spätestens ab
dem 28 dezember also gelten
erstens
mit blick auf die ersten erfahrungen mit
omikron in anderen ländern ist zu
erwarten dass die zahl der infektionen
auch bei uns deutlich ansteigen wird
mehr infizierte bedeutet einen erheblich
höheren krankenstand als in jeder
anderen phase dieser pandemie
deshalb fordern wir alle betriebe der
kritischen infrastruktur auf vor allem
feuerwehr polizei rettungsdienste
krankenhäuser die pandemie pläne zu
überarbeiten oder zu aktivieren wie sie
trotz hohen krankenstand der belegschaft
die kern versorgung aufrechterhalten
entsprechende pläne werden so
vorbereitet übrigens auch für
elektrizitätsversorgung und andere dazu
gehören damit sie schnell und
unkompliziert wirken
zweiter
die harten beschränkung für ungeimpfte
bleiben erhalten 3g am arbeitsplatz das
heißt nur wer geimpft oder gelesen unser
tagesaktuell getestet es darf in seinen
arbeitsplatz gehen oder bus und bahn
benutzen
noch strenger ist es im einzelhandel in
kinos und theatern hier haben nur
gedämpfte oder genesene zutritt es gilt
also die 2g regel und manchmal zweig
plus und je nach regionalen pandemie
geschehen kann für die geimpften gewesen
eben dieser zusätzliche tests nötig sein
das waren wir schon erwähnte zweig plus
außerdem gelten die strikten auflagen
für private begegnung von ungeimpften
weiter es sind nur treffen im eigenen
haushalt und mit maximal zwei personen
aus einem anderen haushalt erlaubt das
gilt auch für die weihnachtsfeiertage
ich darf die wirbeln und bürger
eindringlich darum bitten sich an diese
regeln zu halten sie sind keine eschen
kamen sondern dienen dem schutz der
nicht geimpften und von uns allen
drittens auch für genesene unvollständig
geimpfte werden wieder gewisse
beschränkungen nötig private zukunft
zusammenkünfte sind auf maximal zehn
personen beschränkt das gilt natürlich
insbesondere im hinblick auf silvester
es ist deshalb derzeit nicht mehr die
zeit für partys und gesellige abende in
großer runde kinder unter 14 jahren
werden bei dieser beschränkung auf zehn
personen wie bisher auch für wie gewohnt
nicht einberechnet
viertens clubs und diskotheken werden
bis auf weiteres geschlossen um eine
verbreitung des virus zu erschweren auch
überregionale großveranstaltungen dürfen
nicht mehr mit publikum stattfinden das
betrifft insbesondere fußballspielen
um die krankenhäuser zu entlasten haben
wir schon vor einiger zeit beschlossen
dass der verkauf von feuerwerkskörpern
zu silvester verboten wird sie kennen
das bereits aus dem letzten jahr
gleichzeitig wird ein verbot von
ansammlung und versammlung an silvester
und neujahr gelten
meine damen und herren ich hätte ihn
gerne erfreulichere nachrichten kurz vor
den weihnachtsfeiertagen mitgeteilt
diese pandemie strengt uns alle an wir
alle sind nur bei und der pandemie müde
das hilft aber nichts wir müssen
abermals zusammen stehen und auch in
vielen fällen gegen distanz halten
wir müssen uns schützen und unsere
angehörigen
wenn wir das tun mit all der vernunft
die uns als menschen gegeben ist werden
wir auch gut durch die nächste corona
welle kommen
trotz oder gerade wegen all dem wünsche
ich ihnen ihren familienangehörigen eine
besinnliche und schöne weihnachtszeit
und einen guten jahreswechsel
in der ersten woche des neuen jahres
werden wir uns mit den
ministerpräsidentinnen
ministerpräsidenten der länder erneut
zusammensetzen um die lage zu bewerten
das wichtigste noch mal kurz
zusammengefasst hier sehen wir es auch
schon kontakt beschränkungen für
geimpfte und genießen private
zusammenkünfte von maximal zehn personen
keine kulturveranstaltungen keine
sportveranstaltungen clubs und bars
werden geschlossen wer die chance hatte
das von innen zu sehen in den letzten
jahren und ja also sehr sehr harte
maßnahmen sozusagen jetzt ab dem 28
dezember wieder auf mich wirken die
krone maßnahmen ziemlich wahllos warum
jetzt neun oder zehn personen überhaupt
nicht 20.30 glaube die politik hat
weiterhin großes problem das zu erklären
olaf scholz hat es nicht geschafft in
dieser situation jetzt klar zu machen
und auch vielleicht ein bisschen in
einer sprache zu sprechen die da ankommt
das war eher eine ziemliche einschlaf
veranstaltung die er dort bei der
pressekonferenz abgeliefert hat und ich
habe nicht wirklich verstanden warum
jetzt diese zahl an personen gewählt
wurde es macht sicherlich sinn clubs und
boutiquen zu schließen in einer
situation wo mir kommen kommen könnte
aber die politik hat sich da finde ich
zumindest schlecht erklärt und nicht
klar gemacht in welche richtung es gehen
wird das ist ein großes abwarten was
kommen könnte man reagiert man weiß aber
nicht so richtig in welche richtung man
reagieren will das hat natürlich auch
mit den unterschiedlichen partnern in
der ampelkoalition zu tun die fdp spielt
jetzt eine große rolle die ihm nicht so
harte maßnahmen will wie andere die
grünen würden es gerne etwas härter die
spd ist so ein bisschen dazwischen und
dann kommen noch die ministerpräsidenten
dazu also eine komplizierte lage
sicherlich jetzt versucht man über die
feiertage zu kommen man hofft dass
omikron deutschland nicht so sehr
treffen wird dass das boostern
tatsächlich besser funktioniert als in
anderen ländern und dann die welle
irgendwie an uns vorbeigeht das ist das
eine das andere ist dass die
ministerpräsidenten uneinig sind michael
kretschmer hat reisebeschränkungen
gefordert und jetzt hören wir dass
winfried kretschmann im zuge dieser
beschlüsse eine protokoll erklärung
abgeben will das wurde uns gerade
bestätigt wo er ganz konkret die
möglichkeit auch von ausgangssperren
wieder machen will also das härteste
mitte dass er von vielen deutschen
gerichten zurückgewiesen wurde als zu
hartes mittel in dieser pandemie das
wurde immer wieder debattiert in den
vergangenen wochen und monaten nun
möchte winfried kretschmann der baden
württembergische ministerpräsident das
wieder möglich machen also die strategie
in welche richtung deutschland geht ist
nicht klar aber was wir nicht gehört
haben ist das wort lockdown trotzdem
fühlt es sich so an wie ihn lockdown
weil das ist so ein bisschen defa wie
letztes jahr ist das so locker und
sozusagen durch die hintertür was wir
jetzt gerade erleben das ist ja eine
semantische frage was ist für jemand
einen lock down für die einen ist
vielleicht sogar schon das sperren der
bars und clubs einer art lockdown weil
wir haben uns an diese
freiheitsbeschränkung ja so gewöhnt dass
man sich schon freut dass jetzt nicht
auch noch restaurants wieder dran
glauben müssen oder dass man sich hurra
mit neun bis zehn personen versammeln
darf also das ist ja mittlerweile eine
dimension die auch völlig absurd ist
wenn wir uns zurück versetzen zwei jahre
zurück wenn uns das jemand erzählt hätte
ja dann hätten wir denjenigen
wahrscheinlich für verrückt erklärt und
diese normalisierung ist durchaus auch
gefährlich in der gesellschaftlichen
debatte ohne frage omikron könnte
deutschland hart treffen wie auch andere
länder
aber die frage ist dann wie und was und
wie reagiert man kommt nur noch einmal
zu unserem kollegen peter ziele noch
immer vor dem kanzleramt peter auch
endlich die frage wie schätzt du die
maßnahmen ein die jetzt aktuell
getroffen wurden wie hast du die
pressekonferenz verfolgt
die pressekonferenz also ich musste mich
dann zwischendurch mal selber wecken
weil bei olaf scholz der ton die nada an
geschlagen hat der war er wie
schlafzimmer als und wie aufwecken also
wenn er die nation wachrütteln wollte
würde mal sagen mit dem mit dem ton
nicht aber was wir feststellen müssen
ist die ministerpräsidenten haben dass
hier mit dem bund beschlossen was man
mit dem bund beschließen kann nämlich
dass man sich einig dass die 16 länder
maßnahmen ergreifen werden den bund
braucht es dafür fast gar nicht mehr das
ist das was ich immer noch nicht
durchgesetzt hat bei vielen leuten auch
in den köpfen die bundesländer sind
dafür verantwortlich der bund kann
bestimmte sachen noch machen aber da
auch nur der bundestag das ist da wo es
hingehört in deutschland nämlich in den
parlamenten und in den ländern das hat
man geändert lockdown das wort gibt es
so nicht mehr der bundestag dann ist
nicht möglich und eine landes lockt dorn
ist nicht möglich die bundesländer
können aber so viele maßnahmen
aneinander ketten oder
aufeinanderstapeln das locker und
ähnliche zustände kommen und da sind wir
dann bei herrn kretschmann bei
baden-württembergs ministerpräsident von
den grünen der diese protokollnotiz will
der möchte also da feststellen paul hat
es gerade gesagt dass man ausgangs
beschränkungen haben möchte die
preisfrage ist wozu ausgangs
beschränkung wenn alles andere zu ist
die frage ist noch nicht geklärt aber
grundsätzlich die ministerpräsidenten
haben jetzt das gemacht was aktuell noch
möglich war zum draufsetzen nämlich ab
dem 28 die kontakt beschränkungen plus
keine großveranstaltung dem publikum
bars und clubs in den ländern dichten
die da diese aus diese ausnahme hatten
also das sind die maßnahmen die man noch
machen kann und ansonsten ist das ja ein
mindeststandards auf die man sich gar
nicht jeder ministerpräsident ist in
seinem bundesland mit seinem landtag
oder mit seinem kabinett frei da drinnen
da drauf zu satteln und mehr zu machen
ich will ja eigentlich hat man sich
mindeststandards und das ist treffend
ihm ja ich würde einmal vorlesen was
jetzt in dieser protokoll erklärung
stehen das land baden-württemberg und
der freistaat sachsen fordern die
bundesregierung und den bundestag auf
schnellstmöglich die rechtlichen
voraussetzungen zu schaffen damit wieder
der volle maßnahmenkatalog zur verfügung
steht aus sicht baden württembergs ist
hierzu mit blick auf die omikron
variante kurzfristig die erneute
feststellung der epidemischen lage von
nationaler tragweite durch den bundestag
dringend erforderlich was dann wiederum
ausgangssperren möglich machen würde hat
diese protokollerklärung irgendeine
chance umsetzung
also sagen wir so um dann im januar
wenden die lage tatsächlich so ist dass
man den notstand ausrufen muss oder die
notlage dann hat die natürlich dann auch
eine wirkung und dann auch eine chance
aber da sind wir wieder bei dem alten
spiel stellt man das alles schon auf
schon schon im voraus fest auf verdacht
fest oder aber stellt man eine notlage
fest werden sie dann tatsächlich da ist
oder wenn sie unmittelbar einzutreten
einzutreffen droht und das ist dann
tatsächlich auch noch im noch im januar
möglich
einigen mag das zu spät sein da streiten
sich die gelehrten da gibt's die
unterschiedlichen denkschulen auch unter
dem ministerpräsidenten
aber man muss einfach mal festhalten
wozu ausgangssperren wenn man ohnehin
nirgends hingehen kann also wenn sich
nur zehn personen treffen können können
sich nur zehn personen treffen wenn die
kneipe zu hat kann sich nicht in die
kneipe gehen hat als kino zu kannst du
nicht ins kino gehen also wozu dann die
ausgangssperren das ist
erklärungsbedürftig aber natürlich wenn
omikron natürlich mit voller wucht
tatsächlich kommt und wenn sich das
abzeichnet dann prophezeie ich mal
werden wir im neuen jahr eine neue
diskussion haben und dann wird die jetzt
festgestellte minderheitsmeinung
vielleicht unter dem ministerpräsidenten
wieder eine mehrheit haben peter tiede
vor dem bundeskanzler abend ganz
herzlichen dank an dich wir wollen hier
noch einmal ganz kurz zusammenfassen was
jetzt also gilt die maßnahmen werden
härter kontakt beschränkungen ab dem 28
dezember also nur noch zehn menschen
dürfen sich privat treffen egal ob die
im chinesen getestet 10 ist die magische
zahl sozusagen keine großveranstaltungen
mehr keine sportveranstaltungen mehr und
clubs und bars die zu machen werden es
wird also
wird also ein bisschen einsam schon das
zweite jahr in folge ein weihnachten das
eben ein bisschen trauriger wird und die
nächste ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die
es dann für den siebten januar
angekündigt